[موسيقى]
يمكنني أن أريك العالم
متلألئًا رائعًا ،
أخبرني يا أميرة الآن متى
سمحت لقلبك أن يقرر أنه
يمكنني فتح عينيك ،
وخذ تجولك بالتجول
على الجانبين وتحت
السجادة السحرية
وجهة نظر رائعة
لا
[تصفيق]
مكانًا رائعًا لم أكن أعرفه أبدًا
ولكن عندما أكون هنا ، من الواضح
جدًا أنني الآن في [موسيقى] جديدة تمامًا من
خلال سماء ماسية لا نهاية لها
[موسيقى
] لقد أتيت  بعيدًا ،
لا يمكنني العودة إلى حيث اعتدت أن أكون
مع آفاق جديدة للمتابعة
وسأطاردهم في أي مكان
[موسيقى
] حيث سنكون
خيارًا رائعًا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى
] حلمت بحلم وذهب الوقت
عندما كان الأمل عالياً في الحياة يستحق العيش ،
حلمت أن الحب لن يموت أبدًا ،
حلمت أن الله سوف يسامح
[الموسيقى] ،
ثم كنت صغيرًا وغير خائف
، وتم صنع الأحلام واستخدامها وإهدارها
ولم يكن هناك فدية لـ
[الموسيقى]
ولكن  تأتي النمور في الليل
بصوت رقيق مثل الرعد
كما يمزقونك
وهم يديرونك  أحلام
[موسيقى]
كان ينام الصيف
بجانبي وملأ أيامي بأعجوبة لا نهاية لها
[تصفيق]
أخذ طفولتي في رحلته
لكنه ذهب عندما حل الخريف
[موسيقى]
وما زلت أحلم أنه سيأتي إليّ
بأننا  سأعيش السنوات معًا
ولكن هناك أحلام لا يمكن أن
تكون وهناك عواصف لا يمكننا تحملها ،
كان لدي حلم بأن حياتي
ستكون مختلفة تمامًا عن هذا الجحيم ، فأنا أعيش
الآن مختلفًا تمامًا عما يبدو
[ضحك]
الآن
لقد قتلت الحياة  الحلم أحلم
[موسيقى]
أه